on dit que vous êtes la plus belle femme
du monde c'est pas juste pour vous
flatter parce que c'est je le lis toute
la journée dans les journaux
ah bon il suffit d'aller
voilà
vous avez déclaré Laetitia Casta j'aime
pas la télé et surtout j'aimerais pas en
faire pourquoi vous trouvez ça frelater
la télé vous trouvez que c'est un monde
relaté
parce que il faut aller vite plein de
choses à dire et parfois on vous coupe
ça a l'air j'avais du mal à poser vos
questions
c'est dommage
mais nous on est vous savez ça nous fait
pas marrer on préférerait aller au bout
des problèmes en parler vraiment et tout
mais voilà les gens s'ennuient ils
zappent c'est terrible c'est ça qui vous
énerve à la télé c'est le zapping
[Applaudissements]
tu sais tu l'as cherché celle-là je m'en
fous qui risque que je veux dire par ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que on se
fout des mensurations on voit qu'elle
est belle on a pas besoin de savoir
combien elle mesure de taille de tour de
poitrine
je parle comme j'ai envie de parler je
trouve que de toute façon elle est elle
est très jolie qu'on a pas besoin de
savoir combien mesure quoi je veux dire
c'est un constat elle est belle voilà
vous êtes sur une stèle et on vous
admire voilà alors non un mètre 71 pour
les défiler c'est embêtant
et encore plus petite
et les petits talons là
bon vous êtes dans tous les cas pas
c'est vrai en fin monsieur Flug et
Monsieur gros nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure
il s'appelle Fluck depuis qu'il est tout
petit il s'en fout lui c'est comme vous
ruguet
ce que ça veut dire si en parlant de ça
Laetitia Casta ce que ça veut dire en
fait ce que ça signifie et ça lui va
très bien en plus vous êtes pas la
tennis pierre je l'ai été oui
c'est son nom signifie joie chaste en
plus c'est merveilleux je veux dire
c'est vrai
je sais pas
elle est joyeuse et elle est chaste elle
a fait ses études elle arrêtait ses
études à 17 ans donc c'est normal le
latin n'a pas vraiment eu le temps non
souvent
on avait parlé et on m'avait dit
alors
c'est elle adore la Corse voilà c'est ça
alors là quand vous avez commencé dans
dans le boulot on va pas raconter toute
votre carrière parce que mais vous avez
dit vous avez refusé la chirurgie
esthétique et vous avez dit pas question
qu'on touche à mes dents ça je vous
rassure tout de suite c'est pas à vos
dents qu'on a envie de toucher tout de
suite mais
oh ça c'est du Ruquier c'est du Ruquier
[Applaudissements]
alors donc vous avez dit pas question
qu'on touche à mes dents non parce que
je pense que ce serait l'empire des
insultes à faire à mes parents
non mais ce sont des vrais justement
elles sont pas parfaites mais ça sert à
quoi d'être parfait
non ça sert à rien parce qu'on ressemble
à tout le monde après et j'ai pas envie
de ressembler à tout le monde j'ai envie
d'être moi-même simplement et d'être
heureuse voilà en fait première photo
vous étiez c'était pour le glamour
italien vous avez c'est une photo Adam
et Eve au début comme ça ce monde vous
dites la télé c'est un peu frelaté de
fois aller vite faut faire l'intéressant
et c'est c'est vrai mais dans le monde
de la mode si c'est terrible quand vous
avez fait votre photo en Adam et Eve la
première fois ça devait être c'était
évident parce que il y avait un jeune
homme en face de moi
et alors
sûrement
et alors et donc c'est pas évident quand
on appelle l'habitude de se mettre
contre un jeune homme et de parce que
non mais c'est vrai et j'avais les
cheveux longs et j'avais que les cheveux
entre les chantres
et je me souviens me demander de me
rapprocher de lui j'étais comme ça quoi
je rentrais le ventre et c'est et puis
voilà
c'est une jolie
vraiment alors bon après il y a eu toute
évidemment de carrière ce qui était
assez drôle c'est la première fois que
vous avez fait un défilé c'était pour
Gauthier quand vous êtes arrivé vous
avez des punks avec des cheveux rouges
et vous allez appeler votre agent en lui
disant c'est vraiment là que je bosse
oui c'est vrai en fait je sortais
l'école et j'avais encore mon cartable
on arrive au casting avec mon père parce
que mon père m'accompagner à chaque fois
et donc il m'attend dehors je monte
j'arrive il y avait une queue
comme ça avec des cheveux rouges des
anneaux partout
et donc je dis mes minces ils sont
sympas ou ces gens mais est-ce que c'est
là où jouait je redescends je vois pas
papa papa tu peux appeler l'agence je
crois qu'on s'est trompé et on fait
Raphaël il dit non non c'est ici donc
j'y retourne et donc voilà Gauthier vous
avez choisi justement parce que vous ne
ressembliez pas aux autres en fait c'est
ça l'histoire vous pouvez lui poser des
questions numéro de téléphone
ce qui a fait par exemple tu as envie de
faire ça dans la vie voilà qu'est-ce que
oui
premièrement c'est arrivé le désir de
départ c'est quoi alors c'est arrivé par
hasard vraiment par hasard j'étais en
vacances encore ce qu'on est venu me
voir et
donc j'étais à l'école j'étais une
petite fille assez étourdi toujours dans
les nuages mon frère travaille très très
bien à l'école toujours le premier de la
classe et moi je récupère ses
professeurs
donc c'est pas normal que tu es pas
comme ton frère toi alors j'avais un peu
de mal à suivre c'est vrai et j'ai tout
le temps en train de m'amuser dehors à
faire mes petits trucs et on m'a proposé
de faire ce métier
je savais pas du tout ce que c'était
donc le mercredi et le week-end après
l'école je commençais à faire des photos
et ça m'a passionné tête
devant la caméra
ouais je m'amuse beaucoup parce que ça
me permet d'être quelqu'un d'autre
d'être par exemple une femme que le
photographe veut que je sois et ça m'a
permis de m'exprimer à ma façon tout
simplement donc vous aimez être
photographié oui c'est vrai
Laetitia je le dis Laetitia n'aime pas
être photographié quand elle travaille
pas sur si vous passez un weekend avec
Laetitia et que vous la photographiez
sans arrêt ça va l'énerver je le dis à
nos amis c'est le spectateurs
je tutoie parce que je me sens à l'aise
et si je me sens pas là je vais vous
voyez est-ce que vous êtes autant amusé
à faire du cinéma autant un musée qu'à
faire des photos je pense que
honnêtement je pense que tout le monde
rêve de faire du cinéma je trouve que
c'est un métier extraordinaire et ça m'a
permis d'apprendre beaucoup de choses
surtout sur moi-même ouais par exemple
par exemple quand on doit dire quelque
chose à quelqu'un ou je t'aime faut
vraiment le ressentir donc à ce
moment-là
on pense à ce qu'on a fait avant quand
on a dit je t'aime et on ressent
vraiment les choses on se comprend un
petit peu plus je trouve c'est comme moi
je pense que c'est comme un une armoire
où il y a plusieurs tiroirs on tire le
rire on tire
je sais pas moi
mais j'apprends surtout
bien elle le sait tu le sais pas mais en
fait ce que tu es en train de dire c'est
ce que dit statistiques c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut servir à l'intérieur de soi
ouvrir des tiroirs à l'intérieur de soi
pour mettre ces tiroirs au service de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas ce qui semble
Astérix elle joue Falbala donc c'est
Obélix
par Dieu c'est ça qui est amoureux
d'elle alors que Arielle Dombasle qui
est sur le même film c'est SIM qui joue
j'imagine bien sûr
bon je sais que vous êtes très discret
sur votre vie privée vous avez raison
moi aussi
vous
non on sait deux choses en fait vous ça
vaut mieux on sait deux choses on sait
quand vous étiez petit vous aviez des
posters de Bruel sur vos murs est-ce que
c'est toujours le cas d'accord
c'était ma génération et
c'est quelqu'un très mignon et qui
chantait bien et qui me plaisait bien
voilà
alors la deuxième chose c'est encore
plus surprenant parce que Bruel c'est
vrai qu'à votre époque il y avait plein
de jeunes filles qui avaient des posters
de bruit à l'époque de la Pizza Pino
mais
il y a quand même quand il avait la
pizza commencé à bouffer
idéal je sais pas si c'est toujours le
cas parce que sinon alors là on est tous
morts votre homme idéal ça serait
Jacques Brel lui aussi il est
morte la personne qui vous fait les
filles
je laisse la personne d'autre le choix
de faire mes fiches j'ai encore beaucoup
de choses à apprendre et pour dire mon
homme idéal c'est un peu trop c'est un
peu trop facile justement je pense que
je recherche pas l'homme idéal je tourne
moi j'ai lu j'ai lu qu'il avait tout
simplement quelqu'un vrai et quelqu'un
qui soit lui-même et qu'il soit sincère
voilà chers amis au revoir
c’était tout le monde en parle voilà
rendez-vous dans 15 jours bon alors
voilà dernière chose vous vous dites
parce que évidemment on se demande quand
on voit quelqu'un comme vous comment
est-ce que on pourrait la séduire enfin
moi à la limite d'âge est dépassé mais
je parle pour des gens comme Laurent qui
sont dans la force dans la force Laurent
qui est dans la force de l'âge
vous vous dites quand même j'aime pas
les boîtes alors là c'est terrible parce
que vous dites je suis un peu mémère ça
veut dire quoi non on n'aime pas les
discothèques elle dit je suis un peu
mémère ça veut dire quoi je suis jamais
seul je suis un peu ennuyeuse vous dites
c'est vous qui le dites hein oui non
j'aime pas les en boîte parce que je
trouve que j'aime bien danser et je
trouve pas qu'on boit ton cuisse danser
vraiment parce que on se fait marcher
sur les pieds il y a de la fumée de
cigarette on a mal aux yeux on a les
yeux gonflés comme ça moi je trouve pas
ça tellement je préfère danser chez moi
ou avec des copains déjà c'est une
mauvaise idée
surtout dans le noir quoi
bon ben très bien non puis pour finir
vous avez dit je suis stupide parfois un
peu bête alors là je crois que c'est de
la fausse modestie parce que le discours
que vous nous tenez là depuis un moment
c'est prouve tout à fait le contraire
tout simplement de dire ce que je pense
qu'il faut remarquer quand même pendant
un temps tous les top models les
mannequins étaient assez c'était plutôt
le look anorexique bien sûr
on a une jeune femme vrai avec des
rondeurs qui qui les femmes peuvent
s'identifier à elle qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on s'identifier à 4 mots moi
je veux bien mais on en
voilà on peut pas tous les jours et on
lui ressemble pas vraiment quand on vous
a proposé Astérix vous croyez que c'est
vous croyez que ça se passait encore
c'est pour ça que vous avez dit oui vous
avez dit je sais pas jouer et en fait ça
s'est bien passé c'est plutôt une récré
pour vous non ouais
des conneries de perdu
une barrière justement ils sont pallier
à la mannequin là c'est pas joué non au
contraire ils m'ont ouvert les portes et
ça m'a beaucoup
touchés comme ça non les gens ont envie
de passer un bon moment ils savent
qu'ils vont passer trois mois ensemble
ils veulent que ce soit agréable
qui vous a fait le plus rire SIM
Depardieu clavier Michel Galabru
avec des bottes
moi j'aime les gens qui sont qui sont
voilà qui sont eux-mêmes tout simplement
merci beaucoup Laetitia et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu